[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم واهلا بكم قال الرئيس
الفلسطيني محمود عباس ان كل الخيارات
مفتوحه امام الفلسطينيين للرد على استشهاد
الوزير زياد ابو عين وقالت السلطه
الفلسطينيه كانت قد قررت وقف التنسيق
الامني مع اسرائيل وهو القرار الذي ايدته
فصائل فلسطينيه ودعت السلطه للثبات عليه
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في محورين ما
الذي يترتب عمليا على قرار السلطه
الفلسطينيه بوقف التنسيق الامني مع
اسرائيل وما هي ردود الافعال التي يمكن ان
تثيرها هذه الخطوه وخيارات الفلسطينيين
للتعامل
معها
في اول تعليق له بعد استشهاد الوزير
الفلسطيني زياد ابو عين على يد قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وصف الرئيس الفلسطيني
محمود عباس ما حدث مع ابو عين بانه اغتيال
وعمل بربري لا يمكن السكوت عليه تهديد وجد
ترجمته في قرار السلطه الفلسطينيه بوقف
التنسيق الامني مع اسرائيل وهو القرار
الذي سرعت فصائل فلسطينيه لتاييد ومطالبه
السلطه بالثبات عليه بل
وبتصعب
الاحتلال اخيرا فعلتها السلطه يقتل احد
وزرائها زياد ابو عين جهارا نهارا وقتله
جنود اسرائيليون كانوا يعرفون الرجل وصفته
واكثر من ذلك فان ذلك حدث خلال احتجاج
سلمي تكرر كثيرا في الماضي والتزم خلاله
الاسرائيليون بقواعد اشتباك تقضي بتفريق
المحتجين وليس بقتلهم لكنهم هذه المره
فعلوها غيروا قواعد الاشتباك مع كبار
الرجالات السلطه فلجات الاخيره الى قرار
يقول فلسطينيون كثر انه تاخر طويلا وقف
التنسيق
الامني تنسيق ولد من رحم اوسلو التزم
بموجبه الفلسطينيون او بالاحرى سلطتهم
الوطنيه بالتنسيق الامني مع الاسرائيليين
لمحاربه ما يسمى الارهاب وبعد قيام السلطه
الفلسطينيه عام من القرن المنصرم ربطت
اسرائيل توسيع ولايه هذه السلطه على الارض
بادائها الامني وقصد بذلك تحديدا قدرتها
على ضبط امن اسرائيل وملاحقه من يهدده
داخل مناطق السلطه بعد ذلك تطور الامر وفق
الاتفاقيه طابع عام 95 ليصبح منع ما يسمى
الارهاب من مسؤوليه السلطه التي عليها
ايضا معاقبه من يقوم به والكف في الوقت
نفسه عن ملاحقه من عمل لصالح اسرائيل او
الحاق اي ضرر به الا ان السلطه الفلسطينيه
بقياده عرفات كما كانت تشكو اسرائيل انذاك
لم تكن تتعامل مع التنسيق الامني باعتباره
كتابا مقدسا وما ان فشلت مفاوضات كام
ديفيد عام 2000 حتى تعرض هذا التنسيق
للانهيار عمليا واحتاج الامر ثلاث سنوات
تقريبا قبل ان يستانف عام 2003 بعد اعلان
الرباعيه عن خطه خريطه الطريق شهد التنسيق
الامني تح مضطردا انذاك وشمل تسهيل تحركات
رجالات السلطه والتعامل على المعابر
وسواها بالتزامن مع ذلك شنت اسرائيل ثلاث
حروب على قطاع غزه وقتلت واعتقلت واطلقت
يدها في القدس استيطان وتهويده وتزايدت
الدعوات للسلطه ورئيسها محمود عباس لوقف
التنسيق الامني وكان رد بعض رجالته انه من
الالتزامات التي لا تراجع عنها حتى قتل
الاسرائيليون وزيرا في سلطته فكان لابد له
من ان
يفعلها لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
رام الله كل من الدكتور نشاه الاقطش استاذ
الاعلام والعلاقات العامه في جامعه بيرزيت
وعبر الهاتف من رام الله ايضا قدور فارس
رئيس نادي الاسير الفلسطيني والقيادي في
حركه فتح نرحب بضيفي الكريمين ولعلنا نبدا
من رام الله والدكتور نشاه الاقطش حتى
نفهم بدايه دكتور نشاه قيمه هذا القرار
الذي اتخذ من ق السلطه الفلسطينيه اليوم
بوقف التنسيق الامني مع اسرائيل نود بدايه
ان نفهم طبيعه وحدود هذا التنسيق الامني
الذي كان حاصلا مع
اسرائيل ما هو معلن ان التنسيق الامني هو
يشمل القضايا المدنيه الكهرباء والخروج
والمعابر المبهم في الموضوع هو حجم
المعلومات التي تتبادلها الاجهزه الامنيه
الفلسطينيه مع اسرائيل وهذا هو موضوع
الحديث وليس القضايا المدنيه لان اسرائيل
ملتزمه بتقديم القضايا المدنيه
والاحتياجات للسكان بسلطه وبدون سلطه وليس
وجود السلطه هدفه تقديم هذه القضايا
وبالتالي الحديث عن هذا الموضوع مهم لانه
اسرائيليا اسرائيل ارتاحت بوجود هذه
السلطه التي كانت تحمي امن اسرائيل بضمن
النصوص المنصوص عليها عندما تتخلى السلطه
عن هذا القرار او عن هذا الخ خيار هي تضع
اسرائيل امام خيارين ان تتحمل مسؤوليات
الامنيه وهذا صعب وان تبقي السلطه وكيف
ستتعامل معها في المرحله القادمه وهذا قد
يعني ان تضطر اسرائيل ان تواجه السلطه
وتجابه وبالتالي هذا اسرائيليا هو خساره
كبيره لانها كانت تعول امنيا على هذه
الاجهزه اما فلسطينيا فليس لدى
الفلسطينيين ما يخسروه بعد هودت القدس
والاستيطان تضاعف اضعاف كثيره في عهد
السلام وك
واسلو والتنسيق الامني وبالتالي الخساره
الوحيده فلسطينيا لبعض الشخصيات في الفي
اي بي والرواتب لكن ماذا مذا عن موضوع
الانساني ايضا ذكر بان اسرائيل تقدم وفقا
لهذا التنسيق الامني تسهيلات انسانيه
للفلسطينيين يعني هذه التسهيلات
الانسانيه الاحتلال مجبر ان يقدمها
للفلسطينيين سواء بوجود السلطه او بعدم
وجود السلطه وليس السلطه تقديم
هذه لان السلطه ليس هدف وجودها ان تقدم
هذه الخدمات وانما التهيئه لدوله فلسطينيه
اسرائيل استطاعت ان تحول جميع العمليه الى
اتجاه احادي بمعنى ان السلطه واجهزتها
الامنيه تخدم اسرائيل وهذا كلام رئيس
السلطه وهذا كلام الكتور صائب ان هذه
السلطه اصبحت بلا سلطه وهذه السلطه اصبحت
فقط تقدم خدمات امنيه لاسرائيل وضح تماما
دع نتحول سيد قدوره فارس اذا ليس امام
الفلسطينيين ما يخسرونه جراء هذا القرار
المتخذ بوقف التنسيق الامني مع اسرائيل
السلطه كما قال ووفقا لرؤيته كانت
تقدم ربما حمايه امنيه لاسرائيل من خلاله
من وجهه نظرك هل التنسيق الامني هو بهذه
الصوره وان كان كذلك ما الذي دع السلطه
الفلسطينيه للقبول به اصلا ما
المقابل يعني جاءت عمليه اقامه الاجهزه
الامنيه الفلسطينيه في اطار اتفاق سياسي
ووجود الاجهزه الامنيه كان لتحقيق هدفين
الاول فلسطيني وهو حمايه امن الشعب
الفلسطيني
والثاني حمايه العمليه السياسيه نفسها
وليس حمايه اسرائيل لكن انا تقديري يعني
هكذا من اجل هذا اقي قمت هذه الاجهزه في
البدايه ولكن تطور العمليه السياسيه التي
افرغت من مضمونها ربما ادخلتنا في نفق
مظلم وفي اطار حاله من التردد التي ما كان
يجب ان تكون وكنا يجب ان نبقى متمسكين في
ان وجود الاجهزه الامنيه او تنسيقا امنيا
فقط لحمايه العمليه السياسيه التي كان يجب
وبالضرورة
الناس والتنسيق الامني في ظل عدوان شامل
ومستمر على الشعب الفلسطيني بتعبيرات
مختلفه اها يعني ان كان من اجل العمليه
السياسيه التي يراها كثيرون بانها ميته
اصلا منذ امد طويل يعني السؤال لماذا لم
يتم اللجوء اليه من قبل السلطه يعني وقف
هذا التنسيق الامني امام احداث جليله اكبر
حروب اسرائيل على غزه التهويد
الاستيطان يعني العديد من القضايا التي
اشار اليها دكتور
نشات السواد الاعظم من كوادر وقيادات حركه
فتح منذ امد طويل كانوا مقتنعون بضروره ان
يتم وقف التنسيق الامني بعد ان اجتاحت
اسرائيل كل مدن البصه الغربيه وبعد ان
اصبحت عمليا في المسائل الامنيه الخاصه
تدخل في المدن الفلسطينيه جميعا وتعتقل
وتقتل احيانا هناك راي عام داخل فتح كان
دائما يطالب يعني سواء داخل المؤسسات او
احيانا حتى في اطار ال الحديث العلني و
الملاء لكن يعني تاتي هذه الخطوه التي امل
ويامل كثير من الفتحاويين ان تكون خطوه
جديه ومستمره نحو قطيعه تامه مع الاحتلال
حيث اننا لا نرى من هذا الاحتلال سوى
تنكيلا وقتلا
واستهدافاً
استراتيجيه بشان العمليه السياسيه التي
قوتها وقتلتها اس سنات سناتي للعبار سيد
قدوره فارس دعني اتحول مره اخرى للدكتور
نشات دكتور نشات يعني نود ان نعرف الان
التبعات المحتمله ذكرت بان الفلسطينيين لم
يعد لديهم ما يخسره اسرائيل هي الخاسر من
وراء وقف التنسيق الامني ما الذي ستخسره
فعليا
اسرائيل
اولا اتفاق اوسلو نص على وجود شرطه لم ينص
على وجود اي جهاز امني المخابرات
والاستخبارات والبحريه وال17 وكل هذه
الاجهزه الامنيه انشئت والامن الوقائي
انشئ ضمن معاهدات غير معروفه فاسلو ينص
على وجود شرطه فلسطينيه الان هذه الاجهزه
هي المتهمه او هي من يقوم بالتنسيق الامني
هي انشئ بعيدا عن اوسلو ضمن اتفاقيات
معينه بالتالي اول تبعات متوقعه اي اولا
ان تتمرد هذه الاجهزه ان لا ان لا لا توقف
التنسيق الامني لان الجزء الخطير في
التنسيق الامني لا احد يعرف ما هو وهم وهم
ينكرون الرئيس يقول في احدى الخطابات هذا
مقدس والجميع قال لا يوجد تنسيق امني الان
التبعه الاولى هو وقف الاموال وهذا اخطر
ما تهدد به اسرائيل السلطه صممت هذه
السلطه ضمن اتفاق اوسلو بشكل الشيطان لا
يندل عليه اسرائيل استطاعت ان تضع هذه
السلطه امام خيار 180,000 موظف رواتبهم
ومعيشتهم متوقفه بوجود هذه السلطه بوقف
التنسيق الامني هذه السلطه ا تنهي سبب
وجودها لانها وجدت ضمن اتفاق اوسلو
وبالتالي زي ما تفضل الاخ قدوره هذا موقف
متقدم من الفتحاويين ولكن فتح باعتقادي
وبتصريح كثيرين من قيادات فتح المهمين
وعلى راسهم عزام الاحمد في مقابله شخصيه
معي قال فتح لا تحكم هناك اجهزه امنيه
تحكم هناك شخصيات من المستقلين هل هذا
القرار سينفذ ام لا اعتقد المرحله البق
السؤال الذي نود ان نطرح دكتور نشات على
السيد قدوره فارس سيد قدوره هل دخل القرار
حيز التنفيذ
فعليا يعني انا لا اعرف ما اذا كان دخل
حيز التنفيذ والحديث يعني هناك لكن هل
بمجرد
اعلان محمود عباس عن وقف التنسيق يكون قد
تم وبات امرا واقعا
هذا ما يجب ان يكون سواء اعلن او لم يعلن
المفروض ان يتوقف التنسيق الامني ضمن رؤيه
كفاح استراتيجيه للشعب الفلسطيني وعلى
الرغم يعني ما اشار له الدكتور بان فتح
تحكم او لا تحكم نحن القوى الاساسيه
القائمه والموجوده اذا كانوا مستقلين او
غير مستقلين فتح يجب ان لا تسمح لاحد ان
يخرج عن السياسه الوطنيه التي يجمع عليها
معظم الفتحاويين وتجمع عليها الحركه
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه كامله يعني لو خضع هذا
الموضوع
الاستفتاء يعني يجب ان يتحول هذا من من
هذه اللحظه الى واقع بحيث يكون هناك قطيعه
تامه سيد قدوره سنر طبعا في الجزء الثاني
سنناقش هذه الجزئيه ومدى امكانيه صمود
السلطه الفلسطينيه الذي يطالبه يطالبها به
كل الفصائل الفلسطينيه لكن الان سنذهب الى
فاصل قصير سنناقش ب ارات السلطه
الفلسطينيه لمواجهه ردود الافعال المحتمله
على قرارها بوقف التنسيق الامني مع
اسرائيل نرجو ان تبقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش تاثيرات قرار السلطه الفلسطينيه
بوقف التنسيق الامني مع اسرائيل نرحب
بضيفي الكريمين مره اخرى تحول الى رام
الله والدكتور نشاه الاقطش يعني عندما
تقول الف صائل وكنا نشير الى هذه النقطه
قبل الفاصل بان على السلطه يجب عليها
الثبات على موقفها هذه المره بخصوص وقف
التنسيق الامني مع اسرائيل الا يستبطن هذا
الحديث توقعات بضغوط قد تحمل السلطه فعليا
على التراجع عليه ما حجم الضغوط الفعليه
التي يمكن ان تمارس على السلطه الفلسطينيه
ومن قبل
من يعني التهديد الاول هو دائما تستخدمه
اسرائيل وحلفاء اسرائيل والدول العربيه
قبل امريكا وقبل اوروبا وقف الاموال وقف
الحوالات الماليه وبالتالي السلطه ستعاني
بالشهور القادمه اذا استقرت على هذا
القرار هذه قرارات جريئه
والتاريخ يحتاج الى قرارات جريئه ومن يتخذ
القرارات الجريئه في التاريخ يجب ان يصمد
عليها ويتحمل تبعاتها وبالتالي المرحله
القادمه هي مواجهه على الصعيد السياسي في
المؤسسات الدوليه يجب ان نتوقف عن التراجع
او التردد في الذهاب الى المحاكم الدوليه
وقد تكون هناك مواجهه ساخنه على الارض
واسرائيل في كل مره كان يتم اختطاف جنود
كانت توجه رساله بطريقه ان القرار بقصف
اجهزه الامن قد اتخذ وهي رساله للسلطه
الفلسطينيه ما دمتم تقدمون ما هو مطلوب
منكم ستبقون موجودين وهذه الرساله للاسف
الشديد كانت تستخدمها اسرائيل ب
طريقه ابتزاز للفلسطينيين انه وجودكم
مقابل الوجود وهذه المعادله فرضتها
اسرائيل التحدي القادم التحدي القادم
بالقدر الذي تحتاج السلطه الوطنيه الاموال
والعلاقات مع اسرائيل بالقدر نفسه واكثر
اسرائيل تحتاج وجود هذه الاجهزه التي في
السنوات الاخيره اصبحت مدربه منظمه وتضبط
الامن 100% لم يحصل اي عمليه خلال السنوات
الماضيه جاهزه تعود الى السنوات الماضيه
اذرني فقط حتى نتقدم قليلا في النقاش
ونستفيد قدر الامكان الى اي مدى السلطه
قادره فعليا على هذا الصمود الذي قلت بانه
يجب عليها ان تتحلى به وبان الشهور
القادمه ستكون
صبه يعني السلطه الفلسطينيه في رام الله
موقفها محرج اصبحت تقدم خدمات مجانا
للاحتلال وحركه فتح تاريخها الطويل اصبح
يحرج جماهير يحرج القياده امام الجماهير
وبالتالي هذا موقف لا بد ان تتخذه بغض
النظر عن التبعات وقد تكون تبعات كبيره
وصعبه ولكن اسرائيل حولت هذا الكيان الى
وسيله لابتزاز الفلسطينيين لاحتلال
الاراضي للسيطره واخرها اليوم استشهاد
وزير اي في السلطه الوطنيه وهو يقوم بعمل
سلمي زراعه اشجار وبتالي السلطه ليس امام
خيار ليس امامها خيار وهذه كلمه اريد ان
اخذها منك واتحول بها لضيفنا الكريم سيد
قدوره فارس بالحديث عن الخيار والخيارات
عباس تحدث اليوم بان كل الخيارات مفتوحه
امام السلطه الفلسطينيه ايه اوراق يملكها
فعليا ما الذي يمكن ان تفعله السلطه الان
بعد ان اتخذت هذا القرار مع كل تبعات
المحتمله له كما كان يتحدث دكتور
نشات هذا السؤال لم يعد مطروحا على السلطه
الذي يجيب ان يجب ان يجيب على الاسئله
الكبرى هي الحركه الوطنيه وبقيا حركه فتح
خياراتنا كثيره خياراتنا ان نقاوم هذا
الاحتلال ان نتصدى لهذا الاحتلال لا يمكن
ان يكون مثلا وقت التنسيق الامني خطوه
كخطوه يتيمه هي
الذي هو الذي تستطيع القيام به الحركه
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه اي يعني امامنا
مسؤوليه ان تفتح جبهه واسعه مع الاحتلال
على الصعيد الدولي واشتباك
في الميدان من خلال حركه مقاومه شعبيه
انتفاضه شعبيه شامله في مواجهه هذا
الاحتلال فاذا اردنا ان نحسم ونطالب
المجتمع الدولي بان يحدد سقفا زمنيا لعمر
هذا الاحتلال يفترض اي ان نتوافق لكن سؤال
سيد قدوره نعم الى اي مدى السلطه قادره
فعلا بالذهاب الى اقصى حد بهذا الخيار قلت
لك السلطه هي ليست اداه نضال السلطه اقيمت
يعني لاداره الحياه الى ان نتوصل لاتفاق
باقامه الدوله الفلسطينيه الذي يستطيع هي
الحركه الوطنيه بكافه مكونات لكن السلطه
هي من تملك الاجهزه
للتصدي الاجهزه الامنيه واعضاء الاجهزه
الامنيه هم جزء من الشعب الفلسطيني وهم
ابناء للعائلات الفلسطينيه وبالتالي يفترض
ان يكون ادائهم منسجما مع خطه العمل
الكفاحي الوطني التي تقودها منظمه التحرير
الفلسطينيه وبقيا ات حركه فتح يعني
المساله هم ليسوا جسما منفصلا عن الجسم
الوطني ادوا ادوا دورهم في مرحله سياسيه
معينه الان ونحن ندخل مرحله سياسيه جديده
تتغير يتغير دورهم ووظيفتهم باعتبارهم
ابناء لفلسطين ويجب ان ينخرطوا في العمليه
الكفاح التي تقررها الحركه الوطنيه وضحت
تماما هذه النقطه اود ان انتقل بدكتور نشه
الى اي مدى باعتقادك الاجهزه الامنيه
بالفعل قد يمكن لها دور
في تصعيد هذه المقاومه التي تتفقان يعني
كلاكما على ضروره التصعيد
منها لا لا اظن ان الاجهزه الامنيه ستذهب
بالتصعيد الشعب هو سيذهب الى التصعيد
الاجهزه الامنيه ستكون محرجه اما ان تقف
على الحياد وتترك الشعب يواجه الجيش
الاحتلال واما ان تقف مع احدى الطرفين
اعتقد تجربه العام 2000 انحازت القوات
الامنيه الى الشعب
ومنهم من استشهد ومنهم من من ما زال يقبع
بالسجون وبالتالي الاجهزه الامنيه عليها
ان تختار اليوم اما ان تستمر في لعبه
الوسط وهذا لن لن يتحقق في المرحله
القادمه ولكن الشعب الفلسطيني سئم هذه
الحاله نحن في مرحله مراوح خطيره جدا
القضيه الفلسطينيه اصبحت في خطر بدي بدي
احكي بشيء مجرد ان لوح الرئيس الفلسطيني
بانه قد يوقف التنسيق الامني
هناك تسريبات من بعض الجهات بان القياده
البديله جاهزه وهذا كلام نوع من الابتزاز
السياسي للسلطه وبالتالي الشع من قب من
دكتور نشات نود ان
نفهم هذه تسريبات سربت لاكثر من صحفي بان
هناك قياده يتم
اعدادها بقيادات اقليميه او بتمويل اقليمي
ودولي لتكون بديل عن السلطه الوطنيه
وبالتالي هذا نو نو من الابتزاز الذي
تمارسه اسرائيل اما ان تقبلوا ان تقوموا
بهذا الدور واما ان ناتي بغيركم وهي لعبه
اسرائيليه لا اعتقد انها ستمضي او ستنجح
لان الشعب اليوم يشعر بان هذه المرحله
اصبحت خطره واما ان ناخذ دوله في السنه في
السنه القادمه او التي تليها واما ان نذهب
الى مواجهه اسرائيل في مخططات الاج الدوله
وبتالي اعتقد الشعب حسن خياره بالمواجهه
ذكرت جمله مهمه اود ان اعود اليها ذكرت
بان السلطه تنهي سبب وجودها اذا ما قرنا
هذا الحديث الذي ذكرته هذه الجمله بما
ذكره ولوح بها عباس مرارا وتكرارا الى
امكانيه اللجوء لحل السلطه الفلسطينيه هل
تعتقد بامكانيه ذلك وان الظروف الحاليه قد
تفرز هذا الخيار من بين خيارات عديده لوح
بها
عباس يعني كان يجب ان يتخذ هذا
القرار في اعقاب العام 2000 عندما قر قررت
اسرائيل انهاء السلطه وقررت اسرائيل ابقاء
فتره الحكم الذاتي الى الى الابد وبتصريح
رسميه نعم اعتقد هذا الخيار يجب ان يكون
مطروح واسرائيل عليها ان تتحمل مسؤوليه
الناس التي تقوم باحتلال اراضيهم حسب
القرارات الدوليه رغم كل السوء اللي وقعنا
فيه باتفاقيه اوسلو ولكن اليوم هناك قرار
دولي بان هذه ارض دوله محتله واسرائيل
عليها ان تمارس ما تريد ولكن يجب ان لا
يستمر الوضع القائم بان السلطه تقوم بدور
المحتل و وترفع كل التبعات عنه من مسؤوليه
الرواتب والصحه والتعليم والامن هذه
المسؤوليه يجب ان لا تستمر على عاتق في
الفلسطينيين يجب ان يكون هناك سقف لهذه
المرحله وهو حسب ما يرى الفلسطينيون يجب
ان يكون خلال عام وضح تماما دكتور نشه
اتحول السيد قدوره فارس ونود ان نعرف وجهه
نظرك في كل ما طرح الان
يعني اولا مساله حل السلطه الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه اعتقد بان على منظمه التحرير
ان تتخذ قرار
باعاده النظر في وظيفه السلطه الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه
بما يعني يمكنا من التحلل من كل
الالتزامات التي ترتبت بموجب الاتفاقيات
ثم ان تنخرط مؤسسات السلطه الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه كجزء اصيل من جسم الحركه
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه ضمن اي خيار يتوافق
عليه الشعب الفلسطيني واعتقد ان الظروف
ناضجه الان للدخول في ايه ثوره شعبيه
عارمه
سلميه هدفها الوصول الى لا نريد ان نستبعد
تحدث عن كل مؤسسات السلطه لكن ماذا عن
الفصائل الفلسطينيه التي بدا موقفها مؤيدا
للسلطه الفلسطينيه في هذه المرحله الى اي
مدى يمكن ان يشكل ذلك ايضا اساسا لهذه
الوحده الفلسطينيه طالما كانت منشوده انا
اتحدث عن الحركه الوطنيه الفلسطينيه كونكم
تركزون في السؤال على السلطه الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه حين اتحدث عن الحركه الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه اتحدث عن حركه بكل مكوناتها
حركه فتح واليسار والاسلاميين الجهاد
الاسلامي وحركه حماس مطلوب تحشيد طاقه كل
ابناء الشعب الفلسطين لكن عفوا سيد قدور
فارس لا يوجد صوت موحد لحركه فلسطينيه
واحده يعني هذا امر يعلمه
الجميع ولكنا تمكنا على مدار عقود من
الزمن ان نناضل كل من موقعه وفي اطار
برنامج تحرري يستطيع الشعب الفلسطيني بعد
ان نتحلى من تلك الالتزامات التي رتبتها
علينا اتفاقيات الغتها اسرائيل عمليا
وموضوعيا حين ذاك تصبح الرؤيه واضحه ولن
يكون هناك شيء نختلف عليه سوى ان ان ان
نناضل معا مجتمعي من اجل حريه واستقلال
الشعب الفلسطيني اشكرك جزيل الشكر سيد
قدوره فارس رئيس نادي الاسير الفلسطيني
وال القيادي في حركه فتح ونشكر ايضا ضيفنا
الدكتور نشاه الاقطش استاذ الاعلام
والعلاقات العامه في جامعه بير زيت كلاكم
ما كنتم معنا من رم الله بهذا تنتهي هذه
الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي
باذن الله في قراءه جديده فيما وراء خبر
جديد السلام
[موسيقى]
عليكم
ه